[Musik]
mein Name ist Hauptmann Gerald Schumer
in meiner Nebenfunktion bin ich
Kommandant daheres Flugwetter
Einsatzgruppe Süd Herausforderung in
meiner Funktion
ist es im Vorfeld einerseits diese Übung
zu planen zu organisieren die Absprachen
mit den zivilen Einsatzorganisationen
durchzuführen und dann tatsächlich für
diese Übung selbst die Koordinierung vor
Ort um die Einsatzorganisationen
effektiv zum Zusammenwirken zu bringen
[Musik]
Markus und ich bin derzeit
Stellvertreter
Hubschrauberstaffel in eigenem Ennstal
wie funktioniert eine windenbergung aus
Sicht des Piloten wir schauen uns
natürlich den bergungsort vor einmal
beim Vorbeiflug an dann wird eine Anflug
Richtung festgelegt und man versucht
dann über diesen Punkt zu kommen der
Pilot sucht sich Referenzpunkte um ein
schwimmen nach Linz oder rechts nach
vorne und nach hinten zu vermeiden das
Besondere bei dieser Gondel Bergung ist
es dass die Gondeln zumeist relativ weit
vom vom Erdboden weg sind und die Bäume
die wurden ja schon erwähnt links und
rechts natürlich die Wipfel und die Äste
durch den Download sich zu bewegen
beginnen und deshalb ist es relativ
schwieriges Hubschrauberpilot wurde eine
eine gute Referenz für einen sauberen
schwebe Halt zu finden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein Name ist Sachs Valentin bin
staubsaftmeister bei die Salzburger
Pioniere bin dort Stellvertretern und
Nebenjob Flugretter die ist Hauptgefahr
oder Herausforderung bei einer
liftberger ist natürlich dass man nicht
direkt am Boden abgerissen wird sondern
in der Gondel und das ist schon sehr
speziell weil ich muss mich so quasi in
der Gondel bei der offenen Tür zuerst
einmal aushänger und das ist immer
Gefahren Moment also da darf man mir
nichts passieren da muss man einfach da
muss man sich sicher sein und dabei
herausholen genauso da ist die Tür offen
als Server steht mitten in der Tür und
bist der hakenkind sein
okay